[Music]
[Applause]
Todd Archer the mothership broke the
news the Dax going to be out six to
eight weeks he's been covering the NFL
since 1997 kind enough to join us on the
program which play was it that Dak ended
up hurting his thumb
it was actually a couple of plays Dan uh
where he was throwing a pass and his
hand collided with Shaq Barrett the
Buccaneers outside linebacker and then a
couple plays later did the same thing
and then his final throw was a a little
screen uh to Ezekiel Elliott and that's
when he ran off the field he said I
can't grip the ball so he he thought
that he could just kind of yank the
thumb and he felt like it was jammed and
then when the doctors looked at it
obviously it was much more severe than
that took him to get some x-ray x-rays
found the fracture and here's the
Cowboys season let's go Cooper Rush
is Cooper Rush going to be I'm not going
to say long term but if I said long term
is six weeks is Cooper Rush going to be
the quarterback for the Cowboys
I tend to believe that to be the case uh
just based on recent history if you go
back to 2015 uh when Tony Romo suffered
a broken collarbone in in the second
game of the season they had Brandon
Weeden as their starter he lasted a
couple games they traded for Matt Castle
from Buffalo he came in and went one and
six and I think that kind of deal that
when they made that kind of sour Jerry
on the old hey let's get a backup
veteran quarterback to come in here now
they had Andy Dalton a couple years ago
that was a different circumstance so I
think this is going to be Cooper rush
they have will Grier on the practice
squad and you mentioned the start he had
a year ago was 325 yards passing against
the Vikings he did a really nice job on
that Halloween night but this offense is
not that offense Tyron Smith was their
left tackle that night they had Amari
Cooper they had Cedric Wilson now it's
cd-lam and guys that no one really knows
yeah I'm wondering about the Jimmy
Garoppolo situation it felt like that's
the knight in shining armor come in and
rescue our season Garoppolo is a no
trade clause I don't know what San
Francisco would want I don't know what
Dallas would serve up as far as a draft
pick there and then if you're Jimmy
Garoppolo are you ready to play I mean
there's too many question marks here
Todd it feels like with Jimmy Garoppolo
Yeah you mentioned to me that the
biggest part of that is what is
Garoppolo Garoppolo want to do because
he has that no trade class clause and
his team just lost Trey Lance we can
blame the weather or whatever we want to
say there's still questions about him uh
when he plays for San Francisco they win
when he doesn't play Shanahan does not
win so it would be better sir for him to
just remain in San Francisco if land
struggles if the Niners want to go back
to him and that would set him up better
long term than having to come in learn a
whole new offense a whole new language
with again a receiver core that is
marginal I don't know the best way to
describe it with an offensive line that
is Zach Martin and a bunch of other guys
uh he might be better served to just
stay where he is and see what plays out
with San Francisco
give me the scouting report on Cooper
Rush
oh that's a good one
solid Dependable uh we'll make the right
decisions not as athletic as Dak
Prescott in terms of what you can do in
the RPO game and getting him outside the
pocket a decent enough arm
um players like him he's well respected
he's a smart guy he's always in the
building
um I think I just described Jason
Garrett from about 25 years ago so if
they can get Jason Garrett then you know
hey Jason lasted what 12 13 years in the
NFL as a backup based on winning a one
game against uh Green Bay on
Thanksgiving in 1994. if they can get
just solid play out of Cooper Rush that
that might be good enough most years but
solid with how this offense is presently
construction might not be in might not
be enough for this team to be alive when
Dak Prescott comes back because it's the
Cowboys expectations are higher that
means the fall is you know from a
loftier perch here but like
realistically how good is this cowboy
team can they be this year the you know
if let's say over the next six seven
weeks they don't have Dak Prescott are
they a playoff caliber too
the division always helps and I I know
everybody we want to prop up
Philadelphia and what they can be based
on the off-seasons they made but this is
still a weak division when you look at
it despite the everybody but the Cowboys
winning in week one so that would give
them hope
um this was a team let's go back to last
night that did not play well even before
he got hurt 134 yards passing he just
looked off the entire game whether it
was the the ankle that bothered him on
Thursday or whether it was the Tampa Bay
defense or whatever it was he looked off
but this was the Cowboys team that was
going to have to lean on its defense to
win games this year something we've not
sit around here and probably 2003 when
Bill Parcells was in his first year as
coach so uh they can still find ways to
win these games but I think they need to
take a four page out of that 2003
formula where they did lean on the
defense did play smart situational
football and that's how you can get by
but uh you know after a game like last
night
I'm sure there's a lot of Cowboys fans
that are already thinking can they tank
for Bryce young can they go get CJ
Stroud gonna come out whatever it's
going to be so the the the weak to weak
nature of this league doesn't set up but
it doesn't bode well for the Cowboys at
the moment based on what we saw last
night yeah I'm just wondering and this
was the eye-opener for me last night
Todd we're talking to Todd Archer ESPN
NFL reporter covers the Cowboys it felt
like they were doing gimmicky stuff on
offense there was a lot of reverses and
misdirections and and normally the
Cowboys would just line up and play
Power football and then I realized they
can't do that you know like relying on
gimmicks on offense against Tampa Bay at
home opening night didn't bode well
doesn't bode well not only relying on
gimmicks doing it on the opening drive
think of the the play that lost nine
yards I think on Tony Pollard's First
Carry uh you know Mike Mike McCarthy
said they had some deceptives in their
game plan that they thought would work
and clearly they didn't and not only is
this a team that would line up and play
Power football but this was a team that
could also always overcome the mistakes
because of the talent that they've had
when it was a Mario Cooper Michael
Gallup cd-lam even go back to the Royal
Moira when it was Dez Bryant Miles
Austin Jason waiting DeMarco Murray and
those guys they could overcome their
mistakes because they were so talented
this team the margin for error is much
smaller especially on offense and again
penalties were an issue last night Taryn
Steele their right tackle had four
penalties three of them came on one
drive this is not a team that can live
that way and expect to win and if you're
Mike McCarthy think about when you took
this job you thought you had one of the
best offensive lines in football
that group never played a game together
Dak Prescott if you missed to say the
next seven games will have missed 18 of
the 41 games Mike McCarthy has been this
team's head coach this is not what he
signed up for but this is what comes to
the dinner one of the Cowboys coach is a
lot of pressure on Coach McCarthy
do you think Jerry was you know he was
it felt like he was far more patient too
lenient uh with you know McCarthy's
predecessor and now does that factor in
the time frame like is McCarthy going to
get the same grace period as as the head
coach
well I don't think you'll get a decade
as much as Jason Garrett got right uh as
the head coach and Jerry has said that
one of the biggest regrets he's ever had
was only giving Chan galey two years I
know by the way that team made the
playoffs both of those Seasons even
though their record wasn't great
um patience with Jerry he always talks
about hey I'm 80. I need to win now this
is a team that you know I believe can
win
you know we'll find out what the Cowboys
truly believe in their team is how they
attack this quarterback spot if they go
out at a veteran find somebody if they
don't believe Cooper rush or if they
want to get something somebody behind
Cooper rush to be the guy but you know
Mike McCarthy's entered the season on
the hot seat if we want to call it that
I don't know if any of that really
changes even with Dak Prescott's uh
injury good to talk to you Todd thanks
for joining us yeah you got it thanks
Dan I appreciate it that's Todd Archer
covers the Cowboys ESPN NFL Nation
reporter